The Church of the Broken God worships the
holiness of machinery, and the God Mekhane
who rules over all things.
What would you do if society as we know it
crumbled, humanity fell from grace, and the
Church took over the world at large?
Would you make your way to the Cogwork Orthodoxy
to upgrade your fragile meat body with some
pristine machinery?
What sort of changes would you make, how are
you going to adapt to the New World Order?
We posed this question to the amazing fans
of SCP Explained, and you told us about all
of the ways you would upgrade your fragile
human bodies to adjust to the new world.
So let’s get right to it and see who would
rise to the challenge and please the mighty
Mekhane, and who would perish as a useless
flesh bag.
Sean Michelson said, “I would replace my
left arm with nerve damage from when I broke
it as a kid and the bionic replacement would
be capable of morphing into any shape necessary
for the task at hand.
(Lock pick, axe, sword, etc)”
We’re off to a great start here, Sean!
You turning your left arm into the world’s
coolest Swiss Army Knife sounds like a heck
of an upgrade!
Now that you’ve accepted Mekhane into your
heart, you’ll never have to go to the hardware
store again!
Quick question, though…what are you planning
on using that lock pick for?
If you’re planning a heist, make sure you
do it safely, and see if you can transform
that arm into a sweet getaway car.
Pyronaught682 said, “I always took pride
in my size.
If I got enhancements at all, I'd get some
that would either make me a proper goliath
or a tall, gaunt, but sturdy frame.
Either way, my presence would be enough to
intimidate.”
How tall are we talking, here?
Slenderman tall?
Empire State Building tall?
Either way, it’s admirable that in a world
where you can be any cybernetically enhanced
thing you want, you’re choosing to just
be big and scary.
Hey, if it’s good enough for MechaGodzilla,
it’s good enough for us.
Ivan Piccinin said, “The most fragile and
exposed part of our body are probably the
eyes: a prototype might be a new model of
artificial eyes can provide an omnidirectional
sight, being of metal they don't need to be
hydrated, making the person with them have
a constant view of the surroundings.
It might also allow blind people able to see
again.”
That’s an excellent idea!
You’ll put the eye drop companies out of
business for good, not to mention how the
global glasses economy would crash, but that’s
a small price to pay for giving supervision
to anyone who wants it!
Maybe you’ll even be able to see why kids
love the taste of Cinnamon Toast Crunch.
KaiserAfini said, “I would seek the most
advanced upgrade I can think of: one that
allowed me to create a research center inside
a black hole, allowing the movement of myself
and anything else I designate to and from
it.
Distance and time are unacceptable hindrances
in the project of optimizing the omniverse,
Euclidean physics only limit advanced inventions
as well.
We must evolve past such limitations.”
Well now you’re thinking outside the box!
Outside of all Euclidean shapes, really!
Not entirely sure what kind of upgrade would
let you set up shop inside a black hole, but
there’s nothing wrong with shooting for
the stars!
Or a gravitational pull strong enough to absorb
stars and snuff out their light, leaving only
darkness behind!
Jos Moore said, “I would attempt to integrate
SCP 294 into my own body, providing limitless
sustenance and a very effective weapon if
used creatively”
Why upgrade your body so that it no longer
needs food and water, when you can just stick
a coffee machine in your chest and have endless
mochaccinos?
That’s a life of luxury.
Plus, SCP-294 can produce non-potable liquids
such as sulfuric acid and even liquid nitrogen
(for when you really need someone to chill).
It’s got everything you need, and now it’s
part of your body!
It might be a little clunky carrying around
a vending machine everywhere, but who needs
to fit through doors when you have all the
banana smoothies you could ever want?
Mason Skorup said, “The skin would be interesting.
I'm imagining a sleek human form, a much more
aesthetically awesome kind of shield.
Flexible and durable, much more resilient.
Body temperature regulation would be the first
issue that comes to mind.
No more glands is a pretty big overhaul.
As well as the fact that your skin is where
all of your nerve feelers are located.
Perks: No acne, body odor, splinters or other
damage.
Cool lights and stuff if you want, that sleek
metallic shine, potentially way upgraded physical
senses.
Cons, you look like a robot, you'd be pretty
conductive (I guess that could also be a perk)
so surroundings of extreme temperatures could
pose threats.
Your skin absorbs a lot of things, so that
would go away, as well as the microbiome on
it.
That would make you much more readily sterile,
but could also vector diseases that jump on
to your exterior more easily.
And another big thing I think of is tarnishing.
We dont want an Elden Ring scenario on our
hands 😂 that being said you would absolutely
kill it at any comicon or drag show you went
to 😁”
We should all be so lucky as to live in the
future Mason has imagined.
Just think of it: throngs of beautiful robot
people in line to get robo-Patrick Stewart’s
autograph at Comic Con before watching a real
live Transformer performance, and all the
while no one sweats or smells?
That’s paradise on Earth right there.
Xavier Rausch said, “I'd personally like
to get my left arm modified for a more industrial
looking one with a similar look to "The Clockwork
Virus" sort of style for my own reasons like;
being able to show off my taste in industrial
stuff, being able to push and carry things
easier with my non dominant hand, or even
just look more proud of myself.
That is what I'd do if I could get my arm
all mechanicalized!”
Who said style over substance is a bad thing?
Rock that new clockwork arm and usher in an
industrial fashion craze.
All the coolest mechanized kids are doing
it.
muhammad ksatria akbar said, “I always wonder
what it feels like to become a toaster”
Boy, do we have an SCP for you!
Jurok404 said, “Human evolution would probably
just be: -don't need sleep -don't need food
-can be quick -can learn faster -cannot kill
scp-682 because nothing can”
Hey now, have a bit more faith in the fully
mechanized future!
If we can beat sleep then we can take on that
overgrown lizard.
Maybe.
Midna Arashi said, “I'd probably go with
a full body prosthesis like in the anime Ghost
in the Shell with several notable changes.
The arms will be transforming rifles with
the option to deploy blades either mantis
style ( i.e. cyberpunk ) or bayonets style.
As for the legs, they would extend into a
form that's similar to the hind legs like
that of a canine or similar animal.
I'd also have a cloaking and enhanced hearing
and eyesight allowing me to see objects outside
of the visible spectrum and listen in on conversions
that are taking place in the next room.
With this setup, I'd say I'll be something
like a soldier or a spy as I'd imagine the
up keep on a body such as this would be high
and military grade.
Just imagine someone with mantis blades and
extended legs jumping at you from the shadows
out of nowhere screeching in your face.
I'd say that any normal people would have
to clean themselves after witnessing such
a sight.”
We’ve talked about a lot of terrifying things
on this channel, but the idea of walking down
the street after a lovely night out at the
robot pub and suddenly seeing a figure leap
out of the shadows, letting out an unholy
screech as it brandishes its mantis blades
and skitters toward you on long, insectoid
legs…That’s going to give us nightmares
for a long time.
Congratulations on coming up with the scariest
upgrade in the comments section.
Your prize is the sheer unadulterated terror
of all unlucky enough to cross your path.
Jacob Rathbone said, “Definitely a robotic
arm that can split into 2 functional arms
akin to General Grievous.
And ears with a voice box that can allow me
to speak and understand all languages, but
the problem that could arise is that my voice
box could glitch and get stuck in a language
or accent for a time.
I think having one of my eyes replaced with
an artificial eye that can read all known
languages would be helpful too.”
Wait wait wait, you’re going to put a voice
box in your ears?
Assuming you mean ears and a voice box that
are separate, this is a pretty useful upgrade!
You could travel anywhere you want without
needing to bring a language dictionary or
a translator.
As long as you hit up the cyber pharmacy for
your regular dose of antiviral software, you
shouldn’t have to worry about getting stuck
on any one language.
Make sure you let people know about your artificial
eye though, so they don’t think you’re
flirting with a wink when you’re just trying
to read a street sign.
Shy-Griff said, “Quite simply, I would infect
myself with SCP-217, and then do what an infected
D-Class did and use SCP-212.
I have no idea what the resulting upgrade
will be, but I will put any of my improvements
to good use.
Edit: I would run myself through Scp-914 on
the “Fine” Setting to work out any kinks.”
It takes a lot of ambition to attempt to DIY
your own upgrade, and there’s definitely
a place for that in this new world.
We love the energy, but before you wind up
hurting yourself with unpredictable anomalies
that might wind up turning you into something
unrecognizable maybe you should put the YouTube
tutorial down, save yourself the agony, and
head to a certified professional instead.
Tyler Tracy said, “What I thought of was
some kind of energy upgrade.
In our fast world, allowing people's minds
and hearts to run perfectly without sleep
would enhance everyone's lives, completely
without side effects.
Sure, there is an occasional report or two,
saying this and that about sleepwalking, or
coming miles from where they had hit the hay,
with no memory of how it happened, but as
for me, friends, I've never been better since
my upgrade.
Get your upgrade, and be your best self!”
Hmm, this seems completely legit to me!
No follow-up questions needed, especially
not about the sleepwalking or waking up in
strange places.
That’s all probably completely fine.
You heard Tyler, get your upgrade today and
be your best self!
Just hope you don’t walk over the edge of
a cliff while you’re getting your eight
hours in.
Chungo McChungus said, “I would have additional
mechanical arms attached to myself so that
I can pet so many more mechanical animals,
like furbies.
They are heralds of our gear gifting God,
I am sure of it.
Maybe have an antenna on my head that causes
screens to produce slight amounts of static
on the picture.
Just for fun.”
So just to clarify, your plans for upgrading
your limited human form in the new age of
machines is: getting more arms so you can
pet the wild furbies that will roam the streets,
and a pranking antenna?
Sounds like you’ve got a great handle on
your priorities.
Chungo McChungus knows what living the good
life is all about!
Seth Cushman said, “Probably would include
solar panels/some way to plug into a power
source, so you can recharge energy while sleeping
or something instead of eating.
Also maybe some sort of light/flashlight thing.
And maybe a machine that converts CO2 back
into O2. also this is more flesh-based so
might not apply, but maybe surgically move
my brain into my chest or something somehow,
so then all my vital organs are in one spot,
and I have just one major weak point (chest)
instead of two (chest and neck/head)”
Where to begin with this one?
The renewable energy and air purification
are all well and good, but what happens to
your neck once you move your brain into your
chest?
What happens to your head?
Will you put your face on your chest or keep
your face and head where they are, just with
an empty skull and the breeze blowing in one
ear and out the other?
Won’t your neck still be a weak point because
your throat and esophagus are there and the
airway could still be blocked or damaged?
I have to move on to the next response before
I get a headache.
Or, as you would say, a chest ache.
Nightigal said, “Built in respirator.
Unless part of this clockwork take over involves
switching to 100% clean energy, and seeing
as you specifically name dropped the sect
that has the whole steampunk thing going on,
a respirator will be necessary to avoid dying
of some lung disease from the increase of
pollutants in the air.”
A very thoughtful, and kind of depressing,
answer.
Why stop there?
Scrap the lungs altogether and eliminate the
need for breathing at all, then it doesn’t
matter how rancid the air gets.
Better get rid of your sense of smell, too,
if we’re being honest.
Young Love said, “Literal finger gun upgrades,
replace my arms up to my elbows, and where
I reload would be by putting bullets In the
base of my wrist, like putting coins in an
arcade machine, with inner workings functioning
similar to a 9 round mag for a .308 hunting
rifle, firing with twice as much force when
shot because my replaced limbs would cycle
back all of the carbon and other gasses back
into the chamber to make it not only louder,
but deadlier with a higher velocity to hit
targets from farther away.”
Finger guns!
Actual finger guns!
Everyone you meet will be on edge, they’ll
never know if you’re just being a cool friendly
dude, or if you’re about to blow their head
off.
They won’t be able to tell until it’s
too late.
No notes, this is just plain awesome.
Cheesyminer said, “I would wish to become
completely mechanical solely for the purpose
of calling anyone that still has exposed skin
"meatbags".”
That’s a perfectly valid reason, and we
here at SCP Explained condone any and all
meatbag bullying once Mekhane has become the
ruler of all.
Laugh at them and their failing organic bodies.
Oh, you’ve got flesh still?
Can’t afford metal skin?
Did your mom give you those internal organs?
Loser.
Francisco Souza said, “I would have a special
compartment in my wrist that stores all the
methane in my body and then releases the pressurized
gas and sets it ablaze.
It's stupid, and that's why it's perfect.”
This is incredible.
You have the chance to change anything about
yourself, and you went with weaponized farts.
You’re right, it’s perfect, and it’s
a great way to embarrass your enemies mid-combat
while dealing a ton of damage.
“Hey honey, how was the battle today?”
“I don’t want to talk about it.”
“Oh dear, what’s that smell?”
“I SAID, I don’t want to TALK ABOUT IT!”
The shy puppet said, “A chain saw for a
hand so that I can "dispose" my enemies more
easily”
And, after a long day of horrific carnage
when you just want to curl up on the couch
and relax, you can chop firewood in a snap!
DwemerSmith said, ”Eliminating individualities
in the brain would cause everybody to think
alike, and no one would disagree or be disloyal.”
Well, this is one commenter who should never
be in charge of a post-apocalyptic society.
Noted.
Just gonna slowly back away from this one…
Atris Hayport said, “I would simply have
my mind uploaded to a computer, once it's
data...
It can go anywhere, and can be put into anything...
My concern is that once I am no longer in
a human body I would lose all emotion and
drive to do anything...
Because usually thats governed by our complex
meat sacs...
But if I had some sort of sliders I could
adjust everything about myself I think that
would be enough...
But the actual goal is to experience everything
and when there is no more universe, when I'm
in space watching everything implode give
out one remaining chuckle as I put myself
in an infinite dream only to wake if the universe
reignites so I can watch it”
This is a pretty grand idea, but one quick
question: If there is no more universe, what
would happen to the computer you’re stored
on?
It would be a part of the universe, correct?
Not trying to rain on your immortality parade,
but the mechanics of this one (pun intended)
are a bit confusing.
You’ll figure something out though, once
you’ve got that superpowered data brain.
Probably.
Prophet of the 8th Legion said, “From the
moment I understood the weakness of my flesh,
it disgusted me.
I craved the strength and certainty of steel.
I aspired to the purity of the blessed machine.
Your kind cling to your flesh as if it will
not decay and fail you.~Litany of the Omnissiahs
chosen”
Hey everybody, the life of the party is here!
Thanks for that, Prophet of the 8th Legion.
It was quick, to the point, and just terrifying
enough to set the tone for the rest of the
day.
Death to the old flesh, long live the machines!
Am I right?
Now go check out “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture
of Shy Guy in Space?
The Shy Guy Questions and Theories” and
“SCP-049 - What Actually is the Pestilence?
The Plague Doctor Questions and Theories”
for more questions and answers from the SCP
Explained community